bull markets don't end without a frenzy
or a fomo right like like that's how
they end and some people are like oh 64
000 earlier this year that was a frenzy
that was a fumble that was nothing if
you were around in any of the prior bull
markets that was nothing compared to
what it is you know what my indicator is
going to be what when we're near the top
is when my barber starts asking about it
that's in 2017 that was right around
when it started happening when we got
around 18 barbers were like hey what's
going on with that bitcoin stuff i i
like uh the indicator of what i call the
resurrection yeah and you know what the
resurrection is
it's when all of a sudden people you
haven't talked to in a decade started
texting you being like yo i heard you're
into this crypto stuff what should i buy
yeah they're i'm not gonna call out the
people who uh it was in 2017 but there
was people who were literally texting me
and i was like
i hope that i'm wrong but i don't think
you know a single thing about investing
and you're asking me if you should buy
xyz shitcoin right and i was like this
is not gonna end well so we haven't
gotten anywhere close to that right
there's still people who think that
could go to twenty thousand dollars
right so like when we see the true
frenzy the true fomo that's when you're
going to know we're getting closer and
closer to the top right john yeah
bitcoin transparency is it's dope
in hypebeast terms it's awesome right
beast terms
what is hypebeast terms i don't even
know
he means culture
culture appropriate terms
it's awesome yeah and seeing these
whales uh even put some coins back on
the exchanges isn't surprising to me
right uh as price goes up these people
are long-term holders but they're
they're selling off a portion of their
allocation towards bitcoin um which is
natural i think right as as price goes
up they they want to take some profits
and kind of play with house money almost
a little bit but um i'm not i'm not
surprised and i'm still bullish on
bitcoin people want to know what's in
your coffee and whether you came from
the supreme store to the show
paulina what do you think
um wait i had a question oh yeah do you
remember that one time that we were in
an uber and um the guy the uber driver
was checking the dose that was that was
in march that was in march i think i
told this story on here before have you
we got in an uber and literally at the
stop signs and the red lights in new
york the driver
kept pulling he kept switching from the
uber app switching to his robin hood
account and he was checking the uh the
dogecoin price and i literally said to
him uh because he did like one time they
did another and i couldn't see what he
was checking i was like hey man what is
that and he was like a dogecoin never
heard of it
and i was like nah what's that and he
was like some coin that always goes up
or like whatever he said and i was like
all right yes like the barber story it's
not because he was a barber right like
you can be a barber and be great at
investing but he never wanted to talk to
me about anything other than movies or
whatever right like sports or whatever
it was and all of a sudden he's asking
about all these x y and z coins and i'm
like all right this isn't good this
isn't getting out of hand yeah
so i have a fun fact
okay so do you know that
okay so do you know what okay so
so a whale right did you know that
there's a humpback whale
like in real life or in bitcoin in
bitcoin no what is that it says uh 5000
btc or more all right and then and then
under a whale
there's shark dolphin fish octopus crab
and shrimp what's a shrimp
less than one btc all right i'm a shrimp
perfect
um i mean look if you think about uh you
can call them whatever you want you
could have all the animals you can go to
the zoo all that stuff but
at the end of the day uh you could see
on chain who owns what and it is one of
the most transparent systems which
obviously brings a ton of value to uh to
the system um i have a question
go ahead
what do you think the grin on your face
because because i don't know if you want
to answer it or not but what
what is the
ultimate price of bitcoin like what like
10 15 years like if i'm just
if i'm just chilling in you know 20 50
years from now i still got my bitcoin
all this stuff what's the price like
what is what is the ultimatum here what
is the end goal uh the end appreciation
price that we get to
bitcoin
at some point will be worth millions if
not tens of millions of dollars
but eventually what happens is you stop
pricing goods and dollars and eventually
be priced in bitcoin so you won't have
to think about a us dollar exchange
price of bitcoin it'll just be i have
one bitcoin and which is 100 million
satoshi's and john's selling that hat
for 50 satoshi's so i know that i can
just buy the hat for 50 satoshi's i
don't think about an exchange price does
the stock market get priced in satoshi's
and bitcoin if we price the stock market
in bitcoin everything is down
that is why bitcoin is the apex predator
of financial markets any asset that you
put against bitcoin
over a long a period of time bitcoin
absolutely destroys it and so if you
denominate a financial asset in bitcoin
bitcoin ends up being the better asset
and so what you get is just price
dropping put it against dollars the
dollar has crashed against bitcoin put
it in gold gold literally fallen off a
cliff against bitcoin stocks falling off
a cliff against bitcoin oil lumber
whatever pick your financial asset every
single one is down against bitcoin
because bitcoin is the best performing
asset over the last decade
and so when you start to think about how
does that end you eventually continue to
get that rise and what people start to
realize is wait a second i'm not gonna
think about one bitcoin equals five
million dollars and then i should go buy
something instead what they're going to
think about is okay how much of my
bitcoin do you want for this right i
tweeted it today the number one thing i
did from a financial perspective was a
couple years ago i started to denominate
my life in bitcoin and what i mean by
that is uh i said to myself okay here's
how much bitcoin i have here's the
bitcoin i get on an income basis i
didn't denominate it in dollars here's
what the the bitcoin was on a monthly
basis here's what my expenses are
denominated in bitcoin and then
that allows me to save in bitcoin and
when i started to do that what it made
me realize was wait a minute rather than
go buy
that
expensive dinner or go buy that thing
that i don't need if i instead keep that
bitcoin it's likely to be worth more in
the future a lot more in the future i'm
a young guy let's say that i've got 50
years right to live
how much more is bitcoin going to be
worth 50 years from now than today a lot
more in my opinion and so it stopped me
from spending money on dumb stuff and
instead got me to focus on it right
there's a there's a website that uh i'm
gonna pull up real quick uh and i'm just
to read a couple of these out because
this is incredible there's a guy who i
can't even believe that i'm going to do
this right now and give people free free
distribution there's a website that
somebody created you plug in things you
bought no it's even better than that he
has things already pre
uh plugged in let me see if i can find
it real quick his name is
uh raw
ooh i think hold on hold on hold on
sorry sorry sorry smash the like button
while i'm looking for this real quick if
we don't get to 1.5 k likes we're not
giving out free merch we've got two
winners from yesterday it's called
bitcoin or stupid shit.com yeah bitcoin
or stupid [ __ ] here's how short.com yeah
bitcoin or shit.com uh shout out to who
made no way
uh fora guess what the first one i
pulled up is what a roku stick
all right hold on before you read it
here's how it works this is so fun click
a button and when you click the button
it says if you bought bitcoin instead of
a [ __ ] shake weight
which the shake weight in uh july 1st of
2009 was 29 bucks that's its release
date if instead of buying the shake
weight the day that it was released
you'd have 14 million dollars in bitcoin
today oh my god how did it know
if you bought bitcoin instead of an
iphone 5 when it was released on
september 20th 2013 you'd have
283 000 in bitcoin instead of buying the
iphone if you bought bitcoin instead of
toy story 3 dvd in 2010 when it was
released you would have instead of the
1099 dvd you would have 10 million
dollars 640 000 worth of bitcoin
toy story 3 dvd there's a bunch of fools
that went and bought the 1099
dvd
in june of 2010 they probably didn't
know about bitcoin but if you did and
you bought bitcoin you'd have 10 million
dollars today instead pretty incredible
last one
kanye shout out thursday night soldier
field see ya building his own house on
this on the stadium floor
if you had bought bitcoin instead of
yeezy 350's
on their release date in june of 2015
they were 399 dollars if you bought
bitcoin that day instead of the easies
you'd have 77 000 today so bitcoin
continues to appreciate while the goods
of the physical
world continue to depreciate which one
did you see pelina the kylie lip kit
that i am wearing right now
okay so damn how much bitcoin will we
have instead 16 000. wait uh
oh sorry sorry no no no 16 000 fiat
dollars you'd have point 33 bitcoin but
do you know how much our instant pot
would have given us
i do i want to know 476 bitcoin
476 bitcoin or dollars when it came out
when it came out yeah so yeah 23 million
dollars wow
pretty uh pretty good y'all better be
making some fire food in there
damn y'all got to make me depressed in
here before we even get the day started
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]